ميدانيا قالت هيئه الاركان الاوكرانيه ان
القوات الروسيه تتقدم في محوري باخموت
وافديفكا رغم الخسائر الكبيره اضافت
الهيئه ان قواتها الجويه شنت في الساعات
الماضيه ثمانيه غارات على مواقع تمركز
القوات الروسيه داخل الاراضي الاوكرانيه
روسيه واخرى دون طيار واستهدفتهم مخازن
لوجسيه
اكثر من 27 غره جويه على مقاطع
معنى من موسكو مراسل الجزيره امين درغامي
ومن الكرام موتور سكيب مراسل الجزيره عمر
الحاج مرحبا بكما ونبدا بامين والتفاصيل
المعلنه حتى اللحظه حول هذه الخطه
العسكريه الجديده التي تم الاعلان عنها
وتعديل البرامج لمواجهه
محمد هذه الخطه تم الكشف عنها من قبل
وزاره الدفاع عقب الاجتماع الذي اجراه
الرئيس الذي مر بوتين باعتباره قائد همم
القوات القائد الاعلى للقوات الروسيه
الاسبوع الماضي والذي ايضا تم من خلاله
تعيين غاليري الدراسه موف رئيس هيئه
الاركان العامه للقوات الروسيه رئيسا
للقوات المشتركه الروسيه العامله في
اوكرانيا الحديث عن انشاء منطقه عسكريتين
جديدتين في كل من موسكو
وليلينغراد اي سان بيترسبورج اضافه الى
محاوله يعني توجيه بعض القطاعات الصناعيه
همم لخدمه القوات المسلحه عبر تصنيع عسكري
وانتاج يعني اسلحه ودعم ايضا الجيش ببعض
المواد وما الى ذلك اضافه الى تعزيز
القوات في منطقتين جديدتين يجري الحديث عن
اليوم ولاول مره على لسان جراسي مفاونا
الحديث عن خيرسون
وزبروجا بانشاء كتيبتين روتين هناك في تلك
المنطقه اضافه الى فرقه عسكريه جديده ايضا
في منطقه كاريليا المتاخمه للحدود الفنديه
بعد
مساعي في لندن الانضمام الى حلف الشمالي
الاطلسي الان نحن همم خطه عسكريه تشمل همم
اولا مواجهه تمدد النيترو كمال تقول روسيا
قربه حدودها الغربيه اضافه الى ما الان
باتى المسؤول في روسيا يتحدثون عنه بشكل
واضح وهو انتقال الصراع بين روسيا والغرب
من مرحله الحرب الهجينه الى مرحله الحرب
الحقيقيه والمواجهه العسكريه وهنا روسيا
تحذر همم على لسان اكثر من مسؤول لها من
امكانيه انتقال هذه
المواجهه
المباشره الى حرب شامله الى عالميه ثالثه
كما قال مدفيدف على سبيل المثال قبل ايام
او الى حرب نوويه في حالنا اذا ارغي مات
روسيا على خساره حرب تقليديه هنا
التداعيات كما ترى روسيا ستكون كبيره ليس
فقط على الدول التي تمد اوكرانيا بالسلاح
او تدعم اوكرانيا في حربها همم طبعا في
المواجهه العسكريه مع روسيا بل على امن
القاره الاوروبيه في همم طبعا او في ظل
عدم وجود اي تقارب عدم وجود اي بوادر في
الدخول همم الى مفاوضات بين الجانبين او
حتى
بوادر لحل سياسي قريب للازمه همم في
اوكرانيا
الحاج في الجبهه الشرقيه على وجه التحديد
باخوط وسوليدار ماذا في اخر التطورات هناك
الملحوظ هو اعلان وزاره الاركان
الاوكرانيه عن او اعترافها بالتقدم الروسي
في هذه المحاور هذه هي المره الاولى منذ
العمليه التي بدلتها القوات الروسيه
باتجاه سوليدر واستمرارها وتكثيف هجماتها
على ضخمه القوات الاوكرانيه اليوم تقول
انها همم ان القوات الروسيه تتقدم في
محوري
من خسائر كبيره على حد او وصفه طبعا هذا
ربما موجود هي الاركان نفسها مجبره على
الحديث بشفافيه اكثر حول ما يجري في ضخمه
همم على وجه الخصوص في ظل التغيرات على
همم على الارض وتقدم القوات الروسيه
الملموس في ضواحي اضاءه ولكن الان تقارير
الاستخبارات يتحدث عن احتماليه حصاري
بمدينه
القوات الاوكرانيه في الصمود وهذا قد يجري
همم ضمن اسبوعين او ثلاثه وفقا ل 30 هناك
وفقا لما تحصل عليه من اسلحه من دورها ان
تغير قواعد الاشتباك في تلك المنطقه الهدف
الان وفقا مره اخرى لهذه التقارير
الاستخباراتيه هو السيطره على مدينه
جاسوار هذه المدينه تقع خلف مدينه اضافوا
على الطريق الواصل بين باخمود وبين
القسطنطينيه
وهو الطريق الاساسي الواصل مع باقي المدن
القوات الروسيه في هذا الصدد تتحرك من
الجهه الشماليه من واقعها في سوريا اضافه
الى تحركها من الجهه الجنوبيه بعد سيطره
على مدينه اوبتنا وهي مدينه حتى الان لم
تعلق عليها على الوضع فيها القوات
الاوكرانيه من جهتها القوات الاوكرانيه
ايضا شنتها جماعه المعاكسه في محور الاخر
في محور صفوفا كريمينا وقائد انها استهدفت
مناطق حتى في مدينه
قطع باستخدامه صواريخي هاي مارس وتحدثت عن
تقدم من ايمن في مدينه كريمينا وتضييق
الخناق على القوات الروسيه عدا عن ذلك
هيئه الاركان تحدثت عن استهداف فيها ثمان
مرات معسكرات لتجميعي الافراد للقوات
الروسيه اضافه الى تدمير عدد من مستودعات
تخزين الاسلحه والذخائر في مناطق سيطره
القوات الروسيه في مقاطعه دونيه